you had a screenplay that was turned
into a film I had went well a couple
things went on I had a short screenplay
that I adapted from a short story and
Ambrose Bierce short story called the
eyes of the Panther and the director
came to me because he knew I was a
writer and this was early on my beat
2003-2004 and he wanted to make a short
and he was focusing on art direction but
wanted to be a director and had this
short story and you know I was writer
and so we adapted it together and and
that was made into a short film that
that look pretty great did a nice job
and now and then I had a play that was
put on
that was like workshops both in LA and
in Chicago and yeah and then in terms of
newer work I have many screenplays now
and and some of those hopefully we'll be
mounting into actual films in the very
near future so yeah finally I'm like
what do you say to writers or any
artists in general that our perspective
of their work and they don't want to
show anyone because it's not done yet
and they keep perfecting it I feel like
I'm the perfect person to epic guys
should because I've been very guarded
about the work and talking about like
that people know I'm a writer but they
don't necessarily know much about what
I'm writing sometimes and and I haven't
wanted to show people certain things
until I know that they're as done as I
can make them and I I don't think you
have to watch yourself but I think I
think you should know you should really
have a heart-to-heart with yourself and
sit down and say self am I being
am I just putting off the inevitable am
I afraid of rejection my afraid of
success what is going on here is it
really done and I can't move forward
because there's some other issue or is
it really not done and if it's really
not done then you have to sit down and
get it done if it's important to you or
maybe if you don't know how to solve a
problem yet you could put it in a drawer
for a little while or you could write
out a list of all the options i play
writing teacher would say when you don't
know how to solve a problem think of
three ways you could solve the problem
and they might be horrible you might
have had two of these ideas and you
already know that they won't work but
you write them down anyway you're like
he could goat here he could go this
other place and you're like I'm not
doing either of those but you sit with
it and this is actually better
breakthrough for me on a couple scripts
where I had a problem I didn't know how
to solve and I would you just brainstorm
your way out of it and you write it down
and I've written down you know I
remember one time specifically writing
down for options for what one way to
solve a particular problem I was having
and none of them were good and I just
SAT there with it until I finally got
the fifth idea and the fifth idea
changed everything and sometimes you
have to wait for that aha moment
but you need to decide what you're doing
at the same time if are you really
trying to finish it or are you afraid of
something you know and I think it's hard
sometimes for people to be real about
that I've had scripts that that I think
are very good but they weren't done yet
and my mom would be like why don't you
get that script out anything like it's
not done and she's a kook it will finish
it and so and you know one of these
scripts that just happened I rewrote
something recently and I just finished
it and I'm it is done and it was not
done for a long time and it's exciting
now because it is legitimately good and
and done and if if a director takes it
and wants to change things of course
that that'll be that'll be changed and
looked at but I answered the arcs like
you know you look at all the things that
you can change and like does this make
sense does that make sense when the
answers are all yes and you don't have I
didn't have any more questions anymore
like all the questions I had were
answered I answered them in writing and
that's all you can do and once that's
done it's kind of like okay I guess I'm
done you know
yeah pat yourself on the back you know
finally but um but yeah I think you just
got to get really real with yourself
about about what you're doing and it's
okay to be afraid of rejection it's okay
to be afraid of someone stealing your
idea things happen we're all afraid of
that if we have an original idea we
think we do you know who's not afraid of
that but but I don't know how you get
you can't it's that thing you can't get
to second base if you're always stuck on
first or whatever i'm not a sports
person or whatever that analogy is it's
true you can't you can't hit home plate
if you're just chillin on third base
it's never going to happen it is never
going to happen and we all need to
accept that and just put ourselves out
there
you